yes speaking of good service I saw this
lady this LSU lady badgering the crowd
about the shots you see this [__] no
what is it oh brother
talk about a speech if you were thinking
about a a career in life performance
perhaps you're thinking
you know oh man I'd like to try my hand
to stand up bro just get up and just do
some [__] like this
you could do this for five minutes rile
up the crowd and the next community and
then you as you're getting off stage the
next Comics getting on stage you'll be
like try to beat that [__]
let me see let this rip
[Music]
[Applause]
she
will grab your penis and put it in her
mouth
[Music]
he will grab your penis he ran that
right up her anus
what happens
[Applause]
she will strap it on and pick you up
wait what yeah was that even supposed to
be
I think she's maybe
um a religious person trying to speak
out against
you know college drinking or something
wait she's speaking out against it it
sounds like she's all for it I I yeah
right yeah the delivery is not too not
too good she's definitely using because
she's getting them hyped yeah all the
guys are like yeah I think her her
thinking was oh
I'm gonna you know get them uh you know
I'm gonna get them
into the idea and then show them that
just after five Margaritas you're
getting pegged after five Margaritas
dude she's sucking on my nipples for
sure yeah after five yeah after flop
margaritas
Everything feels good
it takes five Margaritas for a runner to
get feeling back in their nipples
exactly
also this this thing about four
Margaritas she'll Ram it in her anus
yeah right man
yeah
what do you saying I think I feel I feel
like ass play is you kind of know if
you're into it you know what I mean
yeah like I don't think four Margaritas
someone's like suddenly like you know
what
let's let's go there and and not only
that not only like let's try it out but
like let's ram it Ram it in there I
don't think so also
I I I I wonder what the percentages of
of men that are keeping it up after four
margaritas
four margaritas and she will take your
soft penis
[Laughter]
and stuff and fold it up and stuff it in
her anus
[Laughter]
still roll that corn dog right between
her fingers
what are you gonna say let me rip that
one more time
oh yeah I'd like to make some more
uh more detailed observations here penis
maybe the shirt tells some stories
just doesn't yeah what does it say no mo
so you're right she's speaking out
against it
dude
this is this is good
[Applause]
he even heard she was like yeah wait no
no
they were cheering and she was like um
Wait no that's bad
she's like no listen to me
yeah she's trying to scare him she's
gonna pounce on your penis
yeah what you know what's really oh no
you know what's really funny a bunch of
women here not one of them agree
when you watch this whole thing they're
all just shaking their head at her like
nah
I'm not I'm not ramming anything in my
ass
bro
also
I like how she puts the you know it's
the margarita only affects women yeah in
her logic yeah you know it's it's only
girls you know
yeah
she's just telling on herself she's just
telling everyone that Margaritas make
her horny yeah exactly
she's like ladies I gotta tell you
something
some you got to stay away from this
drink it's called a margarita
it'll bring the dog out of you trust me
and I kind of like how it's she's not
making it about tequila this is more
about the sugar
yeah and then yeah
it's more of a commentary on like a
sugary drink yeah
yeah all right keep playing your penis
specific
and put it in her mouth
you'll pause
that's how nasty a dude's penis is that
a woman has to be wasted to even
consider
like I I have to have no sense of smell
to even give this a shot
20. you're going
[Applause]
two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
it happens after five
[Music]
[Applause]
dude I'm a confused cheer that last one
there was one guy in the audience who
texted his girlfriend babe you need to
drink five Margaritas right now yeah and
then all the rest of them are like
conditioned to say yes after whatever it
is she's about to say yeah then they she
says and they're like yeah
yeah
okay now I'm with you I see your message
I'm not down for that
that's crazy man a margarita is so
powerful that
uh it I guess is she saying that you as
a man turn into a hoe
I don't know you know because she's
making it sound like levels one through
four it's the ladies that need to stop
being hoes but then level five
five level Thinking by the way as far as
five level thinking goes
uh you know our you know our boy Leon
Hendricks
and uh Mr Poop test himself you know
they they saw the clip yeah oh yeah did
they really yeah I was talking with Mr
Leon what do you say
you know he uh he posted a couple times
and then he humbly stated why are we so
easy to make fun of LOL and I just
messaged him I said you guys are good
man teach us how to reverse age
and he said maybe a fun idea for your
show to do a poop test and then he said
or or test your own biological age and
Pace uh again and start a poop test
movement
and I said we talked about doing an
enema with you guys on our bonus episode
I don't even know if we did that
why
I thought I thought we joked about doing
like an enema or something so I I quoted
that okay I think
but then I said uh I said when I'm home
let's bring a full circle and let's uh
let's all take a poop test for the show
and he said they were good we should do
that let's do it yeah let's have them on
the show and yeah take a poop test
um
to get my blood worked on next week
yeah I had one and I got some risky
things going on so you should do that
man wait what do you got going on
uh
I have like a unique blood type that is
naturally stickier and this is something
that like a quarter of Americans
experience so leaves me a little bit
more prone
to the old
cardiovascular threats let's see and
there's nothing that can really
you know
um there's other things that like the
way my body breaks down cholesterol and
stuff
it's not very efficient so it's like a
nice combo for a bad situation which
makes sense because uh the boys get
heart disease in my family so I see I
gotta I gotta be on top but let Hold On
Let's uh let's see what's up with be a
ho no mo is there anything else besides
this shop
you know is there anything on the
website
nope
it's just the shirt online
and then there's an anti-maxx
oh nice nice oh yeah we got some Biden
right here there are three three things
in this world a Facebook just don't even
say this we're gonna get demonetized